I thought this myth was over but I've
seen it in news articles and in my
comments section you still need to
reapply mineral sunscreen this myth
comes from the idea that sunscreens are
broken down by exposure to sunlight but
this isn't the case most sunscreens are
photo stable enough that they can absorb
UV for hours before there's any big drop
in protection the reason you need to
reapply is because that film doesn't
stay intact on your skin especially if
you're active your skin moves you sweat
you produce oil water evaporates from
your skin that's called trans epidermal
water loss you brush up against stuff
this happens to both chemical and
physical sunscreen